une balade artistique en vallée de
chevreuse c'est ce que vous propose
l'association hélium jusqu'au 31 août
découverte des oeuvres d'une
cinquantaine d'artistes une alternative
aux expositions est traditionnel célia
gars de saint gobain ce mardi soir
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
cette exposition où est-ce qu'on peut la
retrouver précisément d'un arbre à
l'autre c'est l'exposition le nom de
cette exposition en plein air qui durera
trois mois on peut découvrir environ 79
depuis la gare du rer b de saint rémy
les chevreuse jusqu'à boulet les trous
en essonne sa part de la gare de saint
rémy en fin de l'aiguillage exactement
et il y a une
ce qu'ils appellent une voix douce qui
est l'ancienne voie de chemin de fer qui
allait de saint-rémy aso et qui fait du
petit mohamed 5 et ki que l'on a investi
en mettant des oeuvres d'art tout du
long
l'événement est organisé par
l'association hélium elle réunit une
centaine de plasticiens des musiciens et
quelques danseurs qui sont en vallée de
chevreuse
les artistes ont travaillé autour d'un
thème précis l'environnement la forêt
les oeuvres doivent s'intégrer dans cet
environnement naturel avec des
installations éphémères ou pérennes
en même temps il n'y a pas que des
manifestations et aussi un certain
nombre d'ateliers
c'est à dire qu'on accueille des gens
pour faire des choses avec eux on a
aussi organisé des rencontres avec les
écoles pour que les enfants viennent
voir des carnets d'activités pour les
enfants pour que tout ça soit a soit
vivant tout du long de l'été et donc ce
sont 56 artistes qui ont travaillé sur
cet événement oui dont cécile bourgois
audic sculptrice et plasticienne pour
cette balade artistique et elle a
composé de deux oeuvres lune qui se
nomme crépuscule d'un chêne se trouve
suspendu entre deux chaînes devant la
fondation de coubertin sur le chemin
avant de rentrer vraiment dans la forêt
et l'autre se trouve dans la forêt là
j'ai choisi de faire une prise de vous
d'une installation qui comporte beaucoup
personnage et c'est une installation de
toutes petites actuelle et qui
deviennent donc dans la forêt d'immenses
feux
vous montez silhouette puisqu'en fait le
jeu avec avec les bâches c'est qu'on
peut utiliser de nous deux nous offre
dans leurs lits les transformant par le
jeu de de la reproduction et la copie
est donc si l'on veut plus
d'explications il existe aussi une
application mobile
oui une application géolocalisée sur
smartphone pourra renseigner les
visiteurs sur les oeuvres proposées
sinon pour plus de renseignements toutes
les explications sont à retrouver sur le
site de l'association hélium et durant
le ces trois mois des temps forts au
sombre seront programmées comme le
dimanche 27 juin au molière où vous
retrouverez des animations et des
spectacles
merci celle d'agathe son goût d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir
je rappelle journalistes pour tv 78